after years of research we discovered
the male and female brain is wired very
differently to him I'm basically a
blow-up doll
oh my god that is what you look like
thank you
well you know that grooming releases
endorphins in the female brain let's
don't forget just this press my cakey
set the Brazilian straightening I like
my hair it looked like Bo Duke from the
Dukes of Hazzard
guys I'm a it was my American accent you
mean you don't know the Dukes of Hazzard
the area responsible for defending your
turf is larger in the male brain I'm a
physical marvel oh I'll try me throw
something I mean anything oh okay so I
wasn't ready for that
women are also more likely to recognize
flaws the hell you're wearing I threw
that thing out like three years ago I
take out the trash so now it's back
laughing the fact you didn't want to be
MMA fighters but still wants to hold the
door open for these gender roles they've
been in us for 20,000 years
as a look you like this look how's it
feel to be dating magician relationships
think work we'll need to work two jobs
why don't we take the drug morally it's
not the one to make it eat people's
faces oh she returned some music on
knowing your brain makes life so much
easier even though people can be
complicated nobody can deny our ability
to get back up yeah yeah yeah you just
said yet nine times yeah can I tell you
something yeah sure I think you're a
physical marvel I see and she thought
jelly jellies not really something you
catch jellies some great eat yeah yeah
buddy those were two peppers in a bag
he's like kitchen gnome chefs
you